Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Tonight's verses of
are regarding an individual
that was considered to be one of the
most staunch
adversaries
of the prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi alaihi wasallam,
one of his greatest enemies
and
one that was responsible
for a lot of heartache and difficulty
that
was beset on the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam and the believers of the time
along with the whole of Beni Hashim.
This individual
continued to urge and urge and urge
Quraysh against the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam and the believers to the
point that they were resorted to
the
land of Abu Talib known as Abalib
or Abalib was a a kind of valley that
was owned by Abu Talib and they were
resorted to that place and they were
exccommunicated by Quraysh.
for a number of years to the point that
they couldn't even muster together
collectively
a grain of wheat
and many of them starved including the
women and the children
and the agreement
to do this to the prophet sallallah.aii
alaihi wasallam and his companions and
his followers and all of Beni Hashim,
anyone who sided with him
to show you the degree
of wickedness.
They decided to do this and they
collaborated in doing this. They wrote
it down as a contract and an allegiance
and they hung it in the Ka the house of
Allah subhanahu wa tala their
proclamation of excommunicating
the Muslim and anyone who was affiliated
with them or sympathetic towards them to
the point that people had to
smuggle pieces of bread in their
clothing when they would go to visit
them so that they could give some of
their relatives something to eat.
Throughout the course of these several
years, this went on for three years.
This man's name is
El Morira
Wal.
Albn
is Abu Jah's uncle
and Albn
he is
the father of many companions who later
would become companions.
One of the most
known of those companions is
W is the son of
and more than five of his children
actually accepted Islam
eventually and one of them being
and he remained upon this
for 13 years and three months fighting
against the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
and his companions at every turn.
Many verses of the Quran, more than 30
verses of the Quran were revealed
addressing.
More than 30 verses of the Quran were
revealed to the prophet sallall.aii
amall
speaking of or addressing.
Now Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in
these verses in
he says
[Silence]
Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala says to the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam
leave to me and leave me be with the one
whom I created alone.
Meaning Allah alone created him and
Allah created him alone.
This has a lot of meaning to it. Why?
Because
did not inherit his wealth
made his wealth over time. As a matter
of fact, his father didn't even claim
him until he was 18 years old.
So
even though he spoke and talked a big
talk, he was actually
inshallah.
He was actually the son of an adulterous
relationship
and his father never claimed him until
he was about 18 years old, which was a
great
shame even in our time. But at that
time a great shame and his lineage
was something that was a very touchy
subject for him. And Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala addressed his lineage in another
chapter
in which Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
and so why does this matter? This
matters because he was Abu Jah's uncle
and they were very jealous of Beni
Hashim. They were very jealous of Benu
Hashim and they did not want Benu Hashim
to outdo them and take over the you know
the greatness of
being the you know the the the main and
hierarchy and and and chief tribesmen of
Quraysh. This was very important to them
and this is one of the leading causes
that led to them fighting against the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam and
rejecting Islam. Why? Because of
jealousy and because of fear that their
position would be would be challenged
if they submitted in their idea in their
mind submitted to the prophet
sallall.aii Wasallam
and by extension if they submitted to
Benuash Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
leave to me and leave me be with my
slave who I created alone.
And then I gave him expansive wealth. He
had a an orchard
that was known to be and it was in if
this orchard of his was in it was known
to be so lush and full that no amount of
harvest could deplete its fruit. It had
so much fruit and bared so much crop
yield that it was not known to ever have
been completely harvested.
So Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
another trait of
is that he was a blacksmith. He was one
of the only blacksmiths in Mecca. So
he was he had a trade. He also had a
lot of trade meaning commerce to Asheam
and to Yemen as Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala said
this was including
and
was one of if not the most wealthy man
in all of Quraysh to the point that when
his
when his caravan would arrive back
from Hashem. It would be impossible for
them to wait for the whole caravan to
come in through one gate. So he used to
actually divide the caravan up through
the gates of Mecca so that he could get
them all in before the sunset. This is
how much this man had. He was the one of
the most, if not the most wealthy man in
all of Quraysh.
In the days of Hajj,
he would slaughter
for roughly a couple dozen days. He
would slaughter 10 camels every single
day throughout the Hajj season for the
people coming for Hajj. And he was known
as Al.
Why was he called the equal? The equal.
meaning when they rebuilt the Kaa, they
had to pull their funds together to
rebuild it. And he took over an entire
corner of the rebuilding of the Kaa
whilst the rest of Qur pulled their
money together to rebuild the other
three corners. And all of Quraysh would
submit their contributions every year to
make the cloak for the Kaa, the
covering. So one year Quraysh would
cover the Kaa and one year he alone
would cover the Caba out of his funds.
That's how much money he had. And for
this reason he was referred to as the
equal. And he was also referred to as
alahed, the loner. Why? because he was
able to with his wealth match what all
of Qur had to put together to match. So
his his wealth was a big source of
pride for him. And number two, his
lineage was a very touchy subject
because he was unclaimed until he was a
grown adult and had children of his own.
Allah Subhanahu Wa'ta'ala says,
I gave him very expansive wealth
and I gave him many children that are so
wealthy and at such ease that they are
present and don't have to travel for
anything. They all have servants that
all serve them to travel. They were
around for all major events and his
children were considered to be nobility.
So whenever they testified
to something, their testimony would
outweigh the testimony of anyone else.
As the scholars of mention, he says,
an Azidsh.
[Silence]
So he says and after all of this he
disbelieves in the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam and on top of that
disbelief
he thinks I'm going to give him more
than what I've already given him
he says subhanahu wa ta'ala indeed he
was one of the most staunch opponents of
our verses of the Quran and I will I
will subject him to an incredibly
strenuous punishment
One of the quirks of
and one of the main reasons he refused
to accept Islam
is because he was jealous of the
prophet's prophethood.
Can you imagine
felt that he had more of a right to be
the prophet than Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam. And he was one of the
people in Quraysh and of the Arabs who
were expecting to become prophets before
they died
because they had heard rumors from the
people of the book that a prophet would
be sent from amongst Benny is beni is
and so they were hoping that they would
be and he was one of them. He thought
that you know you were given prophethood
but I'm older than you. In one narration
he said to the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam he said you were made a
prophet. I'm older than you and I have
far more money and resources than you.
And so he was jealous that he wasn't
made a prophet before. Now we're
mentioning all these things and
something that we're going to talk about
in the next sitting inshallah
is the amount of psychological pressure
and influence someone this has on
the larger community.
Right? This was a very respected man. As
a matter of fact
was not a stupid man. He was very wise.
He was considered wise and considered to
be a man of upstanding character. Why?
Even in his time in Jahilia, he was
known to never have touched a drop of
alcohol. And it was his view that
alcohol should be outlawed because it
made men into animals, into beasts.
These were one of his quirks. These were
not purely evil men. These were men that
had a lot of good traits.
But the issue is not about the amount of
good traits compared to the amount of
bad traits. The issue is what kind of
good traits and what kind of bad traits.
This is something we will touch on
inshallah in our next sitting.
[Arabic recitation]